it felt great I mean it was it was a
wild time uh my my father passed like
day before so I got my family in the
room and I was like I just got
[Music]
bre
hot breath what's goody hot breath of
verse welcome back to Hot Breath the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros I your host and comedian Joel buers
and after over 400 interviews with
comedians on this show we are doing our
first live event and to celebrate our
first live event we are bringing back
our first guest ever way back in 2017
this this comic came on the show after
opening for Dave Chappelle being on
NBC's Last Comic Standing and winning
laughing skullfest since hot breath he
has gone on to be on Jimmy Fallon James
Cordon written for several television
shows and he just recently recorded his
debut comedy special ladies and
gentlemen hop Brethren and sister
welcome to the hop Breet verse Mr Rob
Hayes everyone Rob
Hayes yes sir yes sir wow man wow what
an INT welcome that was amazing yo you
got water we out
here you like that oh yeah you want to
you want to should we kick it off with
some yeah let's kick it I hope this is
water this is water cheers cheers to the
the first I mess that up I definitely
drink before the cheers
uh-uh ah this one's a little bit
different from the first one we did
right right right there's less people
yeah
but we had a we were in a concrete room
was like an old like classroom that I
had where I was teaching comedy and you
you pulled up and did the first ever it
was on borrowed equipment that it wasn't
even mine and we made it happen yeah and
now we're look at us 400 yeah over 400
now dude yeah jeez yeah that's a lot
that's a lot that's a lot of breath a
lot of hot breath yeah yeah but that's
why I wanted to celebrate this with you
man man thank you thank you for having
me on your yeah
400 also just you know first guest
coming back yo I mean I've been
following your career since the jump and
I actually just watched your comedy
special taping and I've got to say what
I noticed from that versus seeing your
early comedy is how much more personal
and autobiographical it is now like yeah
like is that I remember even on your
Fallon set you one of my favorite bits
is like the are we swiping or chipping
the you know and then I watch your
special and it has a lot more personal
and like close stuff to Rob is that like
an intentional Evolution or how do you
kind of get to that point in your career
not at all like for the longest I think
one of my fights was fighting against
the you got to be like I'm this person
and I look like a cross between blah
blah blah and blah blah blah and like
all the stuff that they tell you to do
in comedy I always felt like they only
tell certain people to do that h like
it's all it's only you know like like
black people they got to get on stage
and be like address the fact that
they're black and I never thought that
that should be the elephant in the room
and then I kind of just got away from
elephant in the room mentality just
period you know and everything was
abstract and then after a while it was
like I have an opinion on
everything do I have opinions on what
happened with me do I have opinions on
my life
and then I started to form those and
then it was like oh I never have to
worry about like I had a issue with a
comic uh accusing me of of stealing a
joke and I was even unaware that this
person was a
comedian let alone their
joke and so you know from that
experience I was like I need to do
things that are more specific to me when
I was on last comic that was one of the
things that they said I don't know
anything about you but you're funny you
know and so I think that's why I didn't
Advance because I didn't have those
autobiographical things and now I'm like
if somebody steals that they're like
they're stealing a part of my life yeah
they're out there doing you know they're
out there like like putting my past in
their story you know which is nuts
that's a crazy thing to do you know how
do you decide what to talk about and
what not to um I think for for this
special I had like uh some stuff on on
the board there was some things that I
knew I wanted to get to and you know
from that it was way easier to
accumulate material with with a a
singular goal in mind and then also
other little small goals so it's it was
more of me deciding what I wanted to
talk about first and then figuring out
the funny and that
oh interesting so and it used to just be
me finding the funny and things and then
stringing those things together so you
write something serious about your life
and then you figure out what's funny
about it afterwards not necessarily
serious just things that are
interesting yeah is it's not necessarily
serious it's just like what are the most
interesting things what are the things
that I hold on to when did I have a
reaction when when did I feel
embarrassed or when did I feel scared or
when did I feel lonely or when did I
feel excited or when did I feel hype you
know it's just just all those things so
for to compare that to like the the
swiping and the chipping card joke you
have which is hilarious but that
probably started from a personal place
too right of like oh I'm at the grocery
store and they're asking me if I'm
swipping and right it's it's an
observation but it's not it's something
anyone could say I guess but it's an
observation anyone can make you know and
an observation that like you know there
was probably tons of jokes about it it's
just I figured out maybe the funniest
way to say it or the funniest way to
intro it m like it's one of those jokes
where the setup is funny and you know
it's they're already laughing before you
even get to the joke part yeah which is
a part of it is like your persona on
stage too though of it is like you're I
think what I what I've learned cuz I've
known you especially since you started
we started together we used to trade
books and and comedy albums and stuff
real comedy nerd stuff like you know uh
we we were all broke uh and so you know
streaming didn't exist and so it's like
hey I have this redacted comedians album
you have the same redacted comedians
other album let's trade you know and and
yeah we we would share comedy yeah we
did yeah we we we shared some Cosby
albums at one time all right no longer
redacted I don't think I knew what
redacted was I I was striking it from
the record but you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah I didn't know what redact there
were also some prior albums in there
there were also some other stuff it
wasn't just we weren't just Cosby heads
you know we were comedy heads like I had
had some George Carlin we had some
Steven Wright we had all if you made an
album we we were circulating yeah yeah
for sure yeah and I'm glad I now know
what redacted means yeah man I don't
know where you were when Trump was
around a lot of things were being reded
think yeah 5 years ago redacted was a
hot hot funny term in these streets Joe
I anything with Trump is very triggering
for me so I can't I can't be out in
there looking like this you know I got
you but yeah you know cuz I I I look
like this but you know I you know his
Ops look like you too yeah this a whole
other team that looks look exactly like
their team it gets really
confusing I'm so happy when they wear
blue ties and red ties like all right
cool I know I know exactly what side
he's on yeah I get it we all look the
same I get it yeah yeah yeah when when
y'all put collars
on you know the T-shirt ones you can
kind of tell like yeah he ain't in the s
it you know what I
mean that t-shirt a little too loose you
know but I knew you in your T-shirt era
now look at you yeah oh Goodwill dude I
was a good millionaire yeah Max anista
Max anista you know the
jokes doing the strip did you do the
strip club show at uh candy shop I did
it I did candy shop yeah yeah I don't
like when they they make the strippers
stop dancing and then put the mic in our
hands I would rather just like have like
if somebody really needs a dance them to
get a dance and also us to having to be
telling jokes yeah it was it was awkward
though they did it for they did it for a
minute I went every single Monday too
yeah no I didn't I didn't go I was I
would hear about it I was very curious
and then I finally went and I was like
yeah this is not you know well you were
you were the cool kid you got on the
cool shows I had to go do like the strip
clubs and the sidewalks and stuff I yeah
I would have I would like if I if I if
that's the only stage available I I'm
going to go to the shrip club for sure
well how did that compare to cuz like we
did all the the rough shows in Atlanta
but then you moved to New York and now
you're like living in a two-bedroom
apartment with four comics and like
you're grinding out there what how do
those grungy shows compared to like here
in Atlanta they're different because uh
in New York there there's shows and then
there's mics mics only comedians go to
mics like if a person goes to a mic
they're probably going to leave
soon because it's like oh this is a club
meeting like I'm I'm in the wrong place
you know and but the way to get on shows
doing well at mics you know you like
moving to New York you almost just
instantly learn how to Showcase you know
if you if you don't already know how to
show showcase because you're trying to
get on shows so you're in front of real
people but the only way to do that is to
prove yourself in front of people who
are at various levels of doing standups
so some people you know are are really
good they just haven't moved on the
shows or enough shows to get enough reps
to feel like they're you know making
progress there's other people brand new
they're they're starting out and in
comedy everyone one assumes you're new
until they know you all my comments are
like hey man get off of him he's just
starting out and it's like no like you
could you could scroll down I mean you
know but that's just the Assumption you
know yeah I mean the I the mic I did a
paid mic in New York where it was in
like the basement of a bar oh those are
the worst I went last those the worst I
went last out of like 20 Comics so by
the end it was me and just the host left
no one there forgot they paid yeah no
one's ever seen somebody so funny that
they're like I forgot I paid to be on
stage you know that's that's the real
thing Advantage we have on rappers like
when rappers start off they got to pay
to perform places all the time and they
see how many shows we do and they're
like man you are rich you
know and like like you know like rap
like we do bringer shows Just Like
Rappers do when they start like like
here all the time I would see you know
like up and coming rappers performing at
different clubs and stuff it's like yo
that that grind is expensive but yeah in
New York there was one or two paid mics
but they were not fun that that's when I
felt like all right I'm at you know this
is the
bottom I you know I left a place where I
was getting paid to perform now I'm
paying to perform you know yeah what
kept you
going knowing that that experience will
lead to something that one joke that one
tag that one Rhythm I got used to saying
something was going to pay for all of it
and when did you realize oh this is
actually like paying off and it's not
just me mentally
rehearsing well I mean I already had
experts throughout when I moved to New
York I was doing colleges I was you know
paying for stuff off of Comedy you know
I I went to eight festivals that year
all financed off of Comedy you know so I
just thought that that was going to
translate I was going to go up there um
what I didn't anticipate was colleges
not you know having a a time period
where I didn't book as many schools and
and having to kind of start over get a
day job you know was a mover was
answering phones I was working at a high
school just whatever little jobs I can
get you know um and and just figuring
out how to pay how to be free at night
and pay
bills that was the whole thing when were
you able to make it full-time cuz I
think I heard you talk about you sold
you actually sold Scripts
at one time and then had to go back and
like get a day job yeah so yeah yeah
sold sold two scripts had to go back you
know go back you know hey tip service I
you know I know I told y'all I didn't
need y'all anymore you know I I be out
here playing you know like it's gotten
real whatever you got you know they send
me to uh take notes they'd be like a
credit card company would you know have
different surveys and stuff and I'm
taking notes never been a note taker
before never did you know I'm yeah I'm
in Excel pretending like I know what I'm
doing and just yeah just all all kind of
stuff but um from there I learned you
know to save my money and and start a
start a company and start a business and
and some of those things and
also um you know just because you got it
now doesn't mean
you'll get it again or you'll get it
somewhere else and just saving a penny
for a rainy day and then uh putting that
first album out helped out a lot yeah
yeah yeah and I didn't even know that I
didn't know like how much a album was
going to change my life but that that
first album really like you know made me
full like kept me full time like there
were other things I start writing on
shows and so uh but I don't I don't have
to move like a writer
like other writers after a while they're
like all right I got to get in a room I
can kind of pick and choose what rooms
I'm in to a degree or what I'mma go out
for to a degree because I have live
shows and I have you know the album and
stuff so how did you how were you able
to like cuz it was jedia right that that
was the album so what still available on
iTunes you know if y'all if y'all want
to purchase it wherever you purch purch
music you can purchase comedy people
don't even know that yeah you know we
pay money to a musician fund like
percentage of our check goes to session
musicians nobody played the drums on my
album you know that's just money gone
you know like they set up destructure
I'm like yo I mess with their Union we
like stuff is possible you know yeah I
what were you blowing money on it sounds
like you said early on you uh you know I
was I was
uh flying people out I was you know oh
like you know I I was buying stuff I was
buying the homie kicks you know it was
like I was doing all kind of stuff I was
yeah you were on I thought I was on I
thought I was on this the thing one of
the shows got like like picked up like
uhhuh it was really like it was about to
happened we were interviewing people I
was going to be somebody's boss my first
room I was going to be like kind of in
charge in charge but also like hey can I
do
that this what we about to do you know
like yeah it was it was going to be
crazy so like people I would get bumped
on shows I be like they don't even know
I'm going to be that guy's boss next
week you know what I'm saying like oh oh
I'm nothing's affected me but also so
free on stage I was so funny and that
everybody stressed out about Montreal I
already did Montreal also I know I'm
about to get this article and when this
article comes out it's going to be a WAP
you know I'm going to get on every good
show in this city so like I and I think
the attitude that I had at that time I
didn't forget that cuz I feel like
that's important knowing that it's going
to be all right is important knowing
that you know like it's it's
it's going to work out like in the in
the confidence that comes with that I
feel like I still have and still can
reach into even when I don't know even
when I don't know how so what do what do
you if something is like a low cuz like
comedy is so up and down dude it's so up
and down but it doesn't have to be so up
like like you can only go down so many
times before you're like all right I'm
going to figure out how to not go all
the way down uhhuh you know I yeah I
might I might hit the top of the slide
but you know eventually I'm going be be
in the slide like this like I'm I ain't
going back down Joe I'm not I'm not
going all the way back you know I might
slip I might slip but I ain't going to
fall you know what I'm
say cool so you you bought homies kicks
I I I didn't get any of those that's all
right I feel you yeah but I didn't think
you wanted them honestly yeah I mean I
didn't think you that was back in the
goodwi days appreciated yeah
yeah so what what do what do you what do
you do now like how how are you what
with the lessons you've learned like how
how do you move differently um I just I
you know I don't while out like I don't
you know like I think early when you're
in your 20s it's just most selfish time
and you are only worried about
in the moment you know you you're not
worried about months down the line years
down the line like right now I move
where like
hey something happens and you know I I
can't physically write I'll be okay for
you know at least a little while you
know hey if something happens and I
can't go on the road I'll be okay for a
little while and so I just I just move
differently you know yeah I remember in
our first interview and this was you
know over seven years ago but it was
like you had already talked about goals
you're setting and how you already had
achieved a lot of them so you're like I
need to start thinking bigger do you
still like how important is mindset to
your success very important very
important I remember I had a a notebook
and I wrote down 10 goals for me in
comedy and then that notebook got
stolen and then uh you know by the time
like like like five years later I had
achieved all those goals it was like oh
yeah I need to like dream bigger and
think bigger but I think also like when
we started there was so little avenues
for stand up like you know there wasn't
you know any any black comedy shows
there wasn't you know last Comic was was
here and then gone you know they had
like like a 4year Hiatus or whatever
they in consistent season after season
after season there was just like one
showcase show on Comedy Central you know
like like internet videos hadn't the you
know it was It was kind of more of a it
was a thing but it wasn't like like it
is now it wasn't social media wasn't
what it is now and so um you know at at
that time it seems like there's only one
way to move you know now there seems
like there's so many different Avenues
there so many different ways of you know
making it yeah and I think that's what I
learned seeing everything you're
creating now is it seems like you're
able to create things around your
interests like yeah you know and you're
like instead of trying to chase a trend
it's like well what am I interested in
and how much can I create around these
interests also I'm showing off a little
bit oh you're flexing yeah I'm flexing
cuz I I I don't want people to think I
I'm performing in room so they're like I
want to hear about Wolverine you know I
want people to think yo he got that
Wolverine joke off in front of adults
you know like they drinking they got
kids at home he out there talking about
Wolverine is hidden you know like like
that's what's going on but also it's
like you know I feel like the the
special is what's in the margin of the
page right like like the special is like
the important stuff and everything else
that's in the like outside
margins is stuff I just like release so
all those clips all those videos and
stuff that's like that's on the outside
that's not even the focus you know I
might perform a 15minute spot a minute
of that 15 is what goes out as the clip
but the rest of the 14 is going towards
something bigger you know and so for the
longest I was only able to show the
middle of the page you see me do a late
night spot you see me do a a showcase on
TV It's the middle of the page and no
one got to see what was in the margins
so now I'm able to show people oh I can
do topical jokes oh I could talk about
politics oh I could talk about something
that happened today or I could talk
about something that happened you know
in the last week or oh I can show a
different angle of something you know
that everybody's talking about and I've
always been doing that it just I had no
Outlet to put that out before do you do
you find yourself almost writing for the
algorithm no yeah no I'd I'd be doing
way there this place would be packed if
I was writing for the
algorithm I achieved my goals take these
chairs it's sold out I wanted it to be
this amount of people here you know
I'm writing what I what I want to write
about yeah I'm writing what I want to
write about and I'm figuring out how to
get it up you know I I was fortunate I
did a show that was like right after NBA
Finals game and I was able to do 10
minutes on basketball premises that I
would never be able to get off in front
of just a average crowd of people you
know and if I did it would it would be
after maybe 15 20 minutes of work you
know of of trust right for me to do that
and then maybe it would hit whether they
want to hear about it or if they don't
want to hear about it so there are
sometimes where I do have some things
that are
specialized but in those Mo moments I
get to flourish you know there there was
a time you do an event like that and it
you just brag about it and it goes away
now it's like oh I could chop that up
now I got fans that you know care what I
think about basketball care what I think
about sports yeah because you wrote for
like the SPs right I wrote for the SS
NFL honors yeah I'm I had a show on uh
Bleacher Report sneak this uh we had
sketches all about sneakers and you know
especially like Athlete Performance
sneakers and stuff so um yeah I you know
technically work work in sports and have
worked in sports for a long time but you
know that doesn't mean people know what
you do that doesn't mean you know like
somebody watching a w show they still
don't really know who did what and what
is what and so now I get to Showcase
that
mhm think it's a good time for a hot
breath water break please if anyone
wants to drink are you selling these is
this is this available to the people is
this a ad right now are we presented by
hot breath water I mean anyone in the
audience if y'all want to pay for him
that's cool which is a wild
name which is a wild name for water hot
breath water legit actually mhm it's not
a bad idea maybe we just had a big big
business break right there hey you know
I got to get a
percentage y'all seen the pitch that's
really what this is about y'all thought
it was an interview I just wanted to
document my pitch for hot breath water
that's what all the kids are talking
about you you like hot Cheetos you need
to wash them down hot breath water
that's the only way to cool it down once
once the Flaming Hots get to you you
just got got to go to hot breath water
we the plug yeah I'm going invoice you
after this so you know yeah I holl yeah
I need some mhm I need some new sneaks
this how you got to sit when you when
you get interviewed in a couch like this
you got to cross your legs like I don't
never cross my legs my F's going to go
to sleep I'm just really I'm just really
doing this cuz because of the couch when
I uh when I interviewed Ali sque he
taught me that that's apparently
disrespectful when you when you point
your bottom of your foot towards someone
apparently that's disrespectful cuz I
was I was doing that to him and he let
me know very quickly that that is not
the move with Mr sadik okay but we cool
in here I was just letting you know hey
if you cross I apologize to the people
at home I didn't mean to point my foot
in y direction you know what I'm saying
continue to support me I I do need it I
would it would never happen again like
I'm I a't I ain't going to do it no more
I promise when am I supposed to point my
feet your feet are always pointed
somewhere it's the bottom of the foot oh
the bottom of the fo the bottom of your
foot yeah yeah yeah it's what saying cuz
I guess that's the dirtiest part of your
shoe yeah that is true there was a girl
I sat next to in elementary school and I
would like pick out like Nike shoes have
the little like thin hair and bone
things I would like pick out the dirt in
my shoes she she thought I was nasty oh
dang yeah yeah she' been a sneaker head
since then like like that like that
I know you always you could diagnose me
as that that's probably the coolest
thing to say for that yeah is head yeah
oh okay yeah
yeah but Oli really because you Ali's
intimidating so like you know when he
says something you listen yeah and I'm
just in a hotel room with just Ali sadik
I was like he could kill me right now
and no one would ever know her care I
mean you were recording but I mean he
can destroy the evidence you know yeah
that's true that's
yeah but he's also one of these you're
talking about social media he's one of
these like ogs who actually use social
media after actually having the skill to
like showcase on show social media like
so many young Comics now are like just
filming open m crowd work and being like
Oh how do I get on yeah yeah know it's a
different it's a different game than
when we started it is a different game
I'm so glad I didn't start in this era
and that that pressure you know cuz it
was it was hard that time to hold on to
jokes that you thought were good enough
to like commodify and now I I wonder if
if there's anybody having those talks
about hey don't put everything out and
then other people like hey I put
everything out and now I'm touring you
know what those conversations are like
you know what what was your transition
into the the writing side of things cuz
like you're what they call like a
multiphen you know you're able to do
multiple things which is aspirational
for like definitely someone like like me
who wants to have multiple things going
on so like how how were you able to
expand to the the writing side um I was
able to expand to the writing side uh
just through applying I was applying for
years and then I finally uh got the the
perfect job for me which was Sherman
showcase which is a a sketch show based
on a on a dance show uh like like a soul
train um but everything's a joke the the
songs and jokes the commercials the
music artists we created all the music
we did we did a lot of work on that show
but it was so much fun and just so
perfect for my skill set as somebody
who's obsessed with the past and and
also just a music lover um it you know
it just was a perfect fit and then from
there I've been working and writing ever
since some of the contacts I made there
you know I I met and and was able to
work write on special events and award
shows and um and yeah just been on from
there did you move to LA for that gig I
didn't I was by Coastal during the first
room um and you know like it it was cool
to leave the room say your idea got shut
down you go to The Comedy Club get your
rock off come back rejuvenated you you
know uh we had another room like during
the pandemic and then it was like oh
this is what other writers feel when
that stuffs get shot down this a long
ride home like I you know I'm not I'm
not there's no comedy club to go to
right now like this is you know this is
wild um but yeah I was by Coastal I I
was living in New York but writing in LA
and then um I ended up getting uh in the
room on another show and and I was
planning on moving to La later that year
and so then I moved and then that show
they pulled the plug on it like six days
into the room so the second Monday of
the room they have a phone call they're
like go on break which happens all the
time a lot of people busy you know the
every boss I've had has had three or
four other things going on they got to
leave take a call they they come back we
all come back they're like yep no more
show so now I'm just out in
LA and I don't know when the next room
is going to happen and so I'm just like
you know fortunately they they they paid
uh us out for for the duration of the
time but I'm holding to that money like
like this I'm like you know I don't I
don't want I don't want to go back to
the bottom you know what I'm saying so
I'm I'm just like you know living very
very
conservatively and just you know getting
on stage mhm I got so Rusty that first
room just being in LA and just you know
there's not not that much stages and
stuff and you know you know me I was
like hardcore like first first week in
Atlanta I was going up four times a week
I got up to like seven to 10 times a
week when I moved I was at like 12 shows
a week when I was you know left New York
so uh that those uh 2 three months of
that room that was the most time before
Co I ever spent not getting on stage and
I came back to New York with all the
rest so Rusty you know started doing
stuff from like well before it started
hey man Michael Vic Tiger Woods you know
like what are my jokes you know what I'm
saying what what do I talk about man
Obama man he did it yes we can you know
like I'm going back back to the
beginning you know brought the kazoo
back yeah everything Rob had a kazoo
back in the day I used I used to bring a
kazoo to shows if I didn't like the song
I was brought up to I'd be like don't
worry I got it I'll play my own song and
then start playing the song on the kazoo
yeah
yeah um but then after that figured it
out and then like like that's the
momentum that that led to
jobia yeah me me getting the rest off
you know and that was that a a goal in
your head of like all right I'm back in
New York I'm Rusty here's how I can
break this rust off or no I was just
like this is what I do I'm back I got to
I got to get nice I got to get back nice
again you know like I I can't you know I
can't just be out here living spending
money and not you know not right at
standup I can't be going on shows Rusty
I found a club
highly frowned upon nobody really you
know what I'm saying you're not going to
run into your your Dave Chappelle you're
not going to run into the gym Chappelle
at this club you know what I'm saying
they let me perform like seven times a
night you know like they they out here
tricking people in the streets being
like yo uh Bill Bird's working on a new
hour people come in they leave they
upset you know they bring me up last
people like he ain't Bill Bird now they
now they pissed but they let me perform
I I I would go up there you know uh and
and also just whatever shows I could I
got that rust offu I got that rust offu
quick you know I feel like in a week in
New York I can get to decent shape and
then and then you know after that I
could really get in like a really good
Rhythm cuz it's also the the city also
getting off the train you thinking about
your joke the whole time you don't got
to worry about finding a place to park
you don't got to worry about driving you
know you just you're just in joke mode
you leave you're get hop off the stage
you're still in joke mode till the next
time you're on the stage you know yeah
when I visit now I do like three four
shows in a night and it's like it's
incredible yeah how did the the Fallon
situation come along you've done Fon and
Cordon yeah so how did how did you kind
of get into that world um I would I I
was going I went for every late night
show that's so that's interesting theme
of like how did you do this thing you're
like well I tried at it for a long time
and then finally got it interesting
thing I don't think people understand
every late night show told me no you
know uh uh one of them ended everybody
was posting their pictures I put up the
notes that I got you know like like
every late night show like pass you know
I would go back and forth with one
uh they see me in person they'd be like
oh no this this ain't what we thought it
was you know like uh you know it it was
a little of of the materials a little of
just what I've already burned on
television I'd already done what you
know at one time was my best thing here
another time what my best thing was
there and so there was that um and so
then after a while I just started for it
I was just like all right I'm going to
make I can't control whether I get
booked I can control what I work on and
I was like I'm going to make a set
that's so
undeniable if I don't get it at least
like I will I will know it has nothing
to do with the set so I'm you know I'm
gonna do the autobiographical joke I am
gonna do the uh you know clean premises
no company names no cursing no you know
like like everything in the
guidelines of you know all the all the
stuff that people trip on with late
night you know original premises not
hacky you know like all the things and
I'm going to work on that every night in
front of people who don't care about
that at
all when you do stand up in front of
live people they don't care about oh
he's getting ready for late night they
don't care about that you better be
funny now so I got I got to be funny now
but I'm putting the rule I'm putting the
the NBC ABC CBS rules on me and that's
what translated eventually created set
that they were just like oh this is too
good to not I did a showcase for e and
it was just a e showcase they just
trying to see who was uh around I
actually was doing a weekend in DC I had
to take the bus to New York and fly out
of New York cuz they they flew me from
New York I didn't want to get sent back
to DC or whatever and so then I took the
bus to the plane I get on the
plane hot burning up I get sick on the
plane cuz I got all these clothes on cuz
I just came from like DC and New York
work in the winter and so
then uh I you know barely get myself
together they have me stay in this nice
hotel by the comedy store I finally just
can like move I get to The Comedy Store
I do the Showcase 10 minutes all late
night you know
available
like crushed mhm the booker for the
tonight's show comes backstage he's like
um you know I thought you were in New
York blah blah blah I was like I am in
New York he was like can you do that set
next
week and then the next week I did that
set at the stand Jimmy Fallon was there
and from that showcase I was the first
person they called to do The Tonight
Show yeah yeah
[Applause]
yeah yeah
yeah it must have felt validating it
felt great I mean it was it was a wild
time uh my my father passed like the the
day before so um I got my family in the
room and I was like you know I just got
this great news but you know should I do
this and and my mom and sister were like
yeah you should should you know and uh
my dad was s for me doing late night and
you know he used to send me other
people's Clips he would take on his
phone and be like d it's going to be on
YouTube like you don't got to you don't
got to record it you know but he was so
hyped and I I remember telling him about
the Showcase and everything cuz um you
know that that was a time where I I
could have been with him but I but I
wasn't I was you know doing the Showcase
and everything and he you know he was
like I know you're going to make it I
know I know you're going to make it and
so um yeah that that was a special
moment for me to just to be able to do
that and I definitely had a moment
before I I walked out there where I
thought about him but um yeah so so
getting that call was like it was it was
you know it did feel validating and I
did have a chip on my shoulder and you
know um I did have the opportunity to
talk about it uh on the show but I
didn't want to do that like I didn't
want to make that moment about tragedy
cuz I felt like I earned it outright I
felt like when I got the you know it's
not like the cornerer calls Fallon's
like well we know this guy just did a
showcase and uh boy do I have a story
for you you know that's that's that's
not what's happening so I you know
didn't want people you know comic brand
you always think about Comics you know I
didn't want Comics to be like man he he
doing that you know cuz because of
what's going on with him you know and I
I didn't I didn't want that but you know
sometimes I do think
oh might have went viral you know
sometimes I do think might have put
butts in the
seat you know what I'm saying I don't
know helped us out today might it might
have been know like there might have
been an angel looking out for me yeah
yeah but uh you know I I guess I got
Integrity dang man yeah that's got to
change the way you move though and the
decisions you make and what you actually
say yes to yeah yeah prioritizing what's
worth your time and making sure you're
around family more and things right
right yeah I was also thinking about the
people who were watching all the people
that I knew were watching and how icky
it would be to you know for them you
know like like finally a distraction
from this this thing that happened and
then it's like all you know I don't know
yeah yeah yeah what if I would have
cried if what if you would have cried
what if I would have cried were were you
thinking about it I'm just thinking like
what if I would have went up there and
cried like I almost cried up here like
this yeah you want to do a second take
where the rooster would went off a lot
the door would have been knocking on the
door if I would to start crying they be
like y we got it somebody crying in
there oh yeah no I want to see that uh
but yeah I I don't dwell on it too much
you know yeah how long ago was that that
was 5 years ago five years ago
mhm
yeah come on man pour one out come on
come on man pour one out you out there
you eating hot
fries we know you are you watching this
you eating hot fries one water you need
hot breath
water already it's so good oh my God
what kind of water is that that's that's
that loud that's that loud that's that
loud pack W that's the exclamation point
I a even yeah man that that pressure hot
breath water that that
pressure we pushing pee around water we
pushing pee around here I I think that
might be that might be P I don't know
push and P yeah I don't yeah pause
should we pause it's I'm just saying you
know push and P is way more divisive
than it was early
2022 is it's making way more of a
statement then then I think you're
prepared for it you know it was it was a
cute thing just not so long ago
now hey you might be taking a side I'm
just to let you know oh word
yeah hey free everybody you know what
I'm saying that's that's how I
feel oh I didn't realize my bad yeah
yeah I got to get up on game yeah man
yeah well man we can uh Land This Plane
a little bit but all right what is um
like what what are you cooking up next I
mean what's the it seems like you've
done a lot of
things in the industry MH and now you
shot this special it seems like you're
doing something oh I'm doing something
for me now in a sense is like the next
move like all right now what is what's
Rob Hayes this special is very selfish I
will say that it is very selfish it it's
also
like you know an origin story it's also
like hey this is what I think is wrong
with me but it's also like I'm a little
petty at the same time you know it's
it's a it's a combination but um the
next thing is you know I think a lot of
people are gonna expect chronologic
Chron all right what what they going to
expect the order to things you know you
ever get tripped up on the word just
like you know what I ain't even going
to with that what you going to do
chronologically or chronology chronology
chronology the other the cousin
chronology yeah yeah yeah some people
probably are expecting chronology I
didn't know redacted but I knew
chronology okay all right all right
that's why we a team that's why we boys
you know you got one way I got you sham
like the album that's right uh but so
but I I think the next the next special
is not
necessarily the next chapter of my life
as much as
it's the same thing but a different
aspect like I think I think you know
fronting is is how I perceive myself how
I'm perceived by others and the big
valentine which is the pending title of
the next project will be more about my
experience with love and what that means
from various
angles and so uh yeah that that's what
I'm working on now and I'm and I'm
already working on it now whoa oh you
you shot one and you already have one
one like the next thing you're working
on I'm yeah it's it's early it's early
like you know I you know I just shot it
so um you know but but that's I know
what it's called I know some of the
jokes I know some of the angles there's
definitely some things that are going to
be in there that I don't know but that's
the next thing standup wise um but I got
I got other ideas for stuff I got ideas
for for TV shows that I I would love to
produce and and uh I have a I have a
play in me I feel like and so um that
you know I I think is is needed um I
think for for our audience that doesn't
typically go see plays you know
um uh and also because I I feel like so
many plays come from existing m cial and
and movies and different properties it
would be fun to to try to make something
that's you know original and unique and
so I have that in me and and also world
domination I plan on taking over the
entire planet you know like this many
people at a time it's going to take me
couple billion days that's all I need
you know what I'm saying if I talk to
this amount of people every day for the
next billion days I'm going have the
whole world you know what I
mean everybody else not trying that
method they trying to reach everybody at
once I'm trying to reach everybody you
know little by little hey this was a big
start to it today yeah yeah did Y and
I'm sponsored the next tour is going to
be sponsored by hot breath water if you
see the hot breath water truck and the
hot breath water girls in your city they
giving them out they got the book bags
is shaped just like this they'll reach
in give you a hot breath rev water
bottle my man well I I appreciate you
doing this man this was really uh I
wanted to i' I've just you know I've
known you since the beginning and yeah
I've I've just been a fan of what you're
doing and I'm excited for what you have
coming up and the things you're going to
you're going to be doing so I really
wanted this after you film your comedy
special your first debut one to be like
all right I want this to be like like a
a time capsule of this moment in your
career kind of like we did with the
first episode so I appreciate you saying
yes to do this I was going through it
the first episode like I this one's a
little like happier I don't know I gotta
go back and listen 2017 I already know I
was yeah it it was a lot going on at
that time like I I might want to go back
and listen to it just to see you know if
I was okay but uh you did great yeah
yeah yeah you did great yeah this this
is on positive note I'm like yeah I'm
I'm going be all right yeah you are yeah
yeah I feel like what's a big takeaway
is that you you're willing to have an
idea aidea and then actually see it all
the way through and you're not afraid to
think big which I think can be very
intimidating for a lot of people right
including myself of like trying to all
right well okay it could get to one
level but what if the ceiling like what
if there was no ceiling you know to
quote Lil Wayne
yeah but I mean I I think that that's
important thinking big is important you
know it's like I when I saw Kendrick I
was like oh man he thought super big you
know everybody's like oh man uh rappers
can't dance and it's like he's got
choreographed dances around him the
whole time and I never felt like oh man
this is corny I felt like man this is
cool you know what I'm saying I want to
go to Kendrick practice Yeah like this
is crazy you know um so yeah I I think
that there are no rules there are no
parameters anything goes so let's let's
have fun let's let's
shake things up let's do things a little
different you know big facts big facts
big facts big
facts yes sir where what's the best
place for people to keep up with you uh
you can find me at Rob haes on
everything I finally uh got the guy on
Twitter aka.com to relinquish Rob Haze
uh he wasn't using he was tweeting like
once once a year you know about his dog
or whatever so now I'm at Rob Hayes on
them at Rob Hayes on everything dope
well uh thank you so much we appreciate
all y'all for coming out and uh Rob
Hayes thanks for being on hot breath man
yo thanks for having me this is so dope
yeah my man oh do we get up I don't know
my man my man good
[Applause]
stuff